I know that Michael Jackson was real
hero of yours and now you you did you
meet him or you didn't meet him there
was a no no I never I know no I talked
to him on the phone yes how did that
happen I would how did it happen I was I
was in Paris and I was with Kenny Ortega
we were promoting High School Musical 3
it was probably 20 maybe 20 21 at the
time and we were at dinner and somehow I
got at that was at the head of the table
and Kenny was on the other side of the
table our director can you write a a guy
and his phone rang and I remember I got
this look like you want this I was like
okay so I came over I was like what's
what's going on he goes it's Michael
Jackson I'm like and I was like Hello
and I heard this is Zac Efron I'm a
massive fan and I'm an actor and you're
like my hero
and I didn't know what to say it was
like kind of I was just at a loss for
words and rambling on and then he said
that's really nice can you get the phone
back to Kenny and I was freaking out
like I just talked to Michael Jackson
he's my hero
tripping and I sat back down just a
little dizzy and then all of a sudden
the phone rang again and Kenny answered
and I saw him kind of confused across
the table and and he like looked at me
again he's like you want to stick okay
and he hints the front of me goes it's
what okay and I picked up the phone I
was like Hello he goes oh this is Zach
from high school musical and I was like
yeah and he was like oh I love what you
do I'm a huge fan I'm and I've lost it
I lost my balance I think I fell over
into the wall I started I was like you
know I just started crying I was a mess
like literally I was just making a
pull-up
I like slid down to the floor
pathetically and professed how much I
loved him said like you're my hero
you're the reason I do what I do like
thank you so much Michael for everything
and thanks for showing me how to dance
how to be you know how did believe in
myself out of how to I don't know how to
shine you know and that made him cry
crying to each other on the phone and he
ended the whole phone call conversation
with something along the lines of hey
Zach and I like stopped crying for a
second he's like isn't it isn't it
awesome and I was like what and he goes
dreams really do come true don't they
[Applause]
[Music]